[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um up
[Music]
[Music]
um
do
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to our elder
scrolls online gates of oblivion year
end stream i'm gina bruno and i'm jess
folsom we have a great show lined up for
you today eso deadlands the final
installment in our gates of oblivion
year-long adventure launches this
november
before it arrives we want to pull back
the curtain and share all the details
about this epic conclusion but that's
not all we have information about new
in-game activities events awesome
partnerships sales and even a special
surprise to close out the show trust us
you won't want to miss anything if
you're new to eso or interested in
trying it out stay put you're in the
right place and if you're a long time
player who's been with us from the
beginning eso fam represent
you'll want to stick around for behind
the scenes details you won't find
anywhere else
not to mention we'll also be hosting a
special post show where we'll expand
even more on everything discussed today
hello to all 19 million eso players and
everyone tuning in from around the world
thanks for taking the time to join us we
greatly appreciate it
19 million that's a big number and i
truly mean it when i say our community
is the best community in gaming
you all play a huge role in shaping the
content and making eso the best it can
be
that includes players from around the
globe eso has played in over 240
different countries with thousands of
communities throughout the world it's
been amazing to see eso continue to grow
and reach new audiences every year
and on that note i have some really
exciting news coming in 2022 we'll be
adding spanish localization to our list
of available languages for eso players
we can't wait to share more details on
this in the coming months
and here to chime in on this news is our
spanish community manager elena
thank you rich for the great news i'd
like to dedicate some special words to
the spanish community now hola todos los
espanol es repartidos portos los lugares
subtitles
gracias
[Music]
and now it's time to talk deadlands
as we near the finale to this year-long
adventure the stakes have grown
increasingly more dire
dagon and his army aren't done yet and
as you dig deeper into the events of the
deadlines dlc you will see just how
important it will be to stop the prince
of destruction the fate of nirn itself
rests in your hands
but no pressure or anything
so how do i summarize the deadline story
you know it's your typical journey to
the plains of oblivion you work with
mortals and remora to thwart the prince
of destruction's plans to destroy nirn
if you believe dagon backed off after
the events in blackwood unfolded think
again
his story isn't over
prince of chaos destruction and change
will always have other plots and schemes
it's his nature
dagon is after something and while we
don't want to spoil exactly what it is
you can guess that you don't want him to
get his hands on it
part of your journey will be to learn
more about just how dangerous it will be
to life in tamriel even to daedra
in the deadlines dlc you'll spend a lot
of time in the you guessed it deadlands
you find yourself doing a lot more than
just fighting daedra while you're there
you get to explore the harshly beautiful
daedric plain and you'll meet dremora
who live and thrive in their own
environment
i think you'll enjoy this new window
into the dremora and into danger culture
as much as the team and i enjoyed
exploring it
you'll see that they're more than just
demonic looking baddies
you're going to explore locations like
no other and run into some unique
characters
and some are willing to aid you and some
they simply want you dead
one of the two major threats in the
deadlines is sister seldina
within the deadlines she's the face of
the waking plane
and she's sworn to serve mehrunes dagon
to see the mortal world destroyed
you'll see her iron will and her
unshakeable loyalty to serve the prince
of destruction
[Music]
next we have dagon's lieutenant falcones
nutraz
he's your classic arrogant strong
ambitious and cruel type of daedra
he serves his prince unswervingly
no matter how much he dislikes any
particular task
and finally we have the anchorite a new
character you'll encounter
in fact she's rather new to herself
she finds herself in a strange city no
idea how she got there
she's a mystery that both she and the
player will want to solve
now i'm excited to give you a sneak peek
at eso deadlands
shall be
mine
there's a lot of new stuff in this
deadlands dlc a special mention is a
bonus series of quests that we call
cappers these quests wrap up the entire
year-long gates of oblivion story arc
and are unlocked when you complete both
main stories from blackwood and the
deadlands additionally we have a new
deadlands prologue quest available right
now on all servers
this new prologue quest introduces the
events that lead into the deadline
storyline
dagon worshipers known as the waking
flame have put forth a devious plan and
you'll travel to their base in a magical
crossroads between oblivion and nirn to
learn more
you can locate the quest giver rogatina
sinha in your alliance capital visit
elderscrollsonline.com for more info
[Music]
the eso deadlands prologue isn't the
only new content in the game right now
bounties of blackwood has arrived in
this brand new in-game event players
take part in a celebration within
blackwood from now until october 12th
work together with your fellow esl
players for a chance to unlock three
epic rewards
every completion of the pathfinder
achievement in blackwood will fill a
metering the more the meter fills the
bigger the prizes get
the first tiered reward will be this
very cool palacid swamp jelly pet
the next reward will be the intricate
shadows of blackwood body and face
markings and if you fill the meter all
the way
we're giving everyone who owns blackwood
the deadlands dlc for free
now keep in mind this limited event ends
october 12th you can check
elderscrollsonline.com for all the
details we told you there was a big
surprise and those are just some of the
rewards we may have a few others that
you can earn during the event as well
remember this event is tied specifically
to the blackwood area of eso so players
will need to own the latest chapter in
order to participate if you don't own it
yet not to worry we've got you covered
for a limited time starting now you can
grab the blackwood chapter on sale
[Music]
back in august during quakecon we
announced our partnership with the heavy
metal band trivium together we've been
collaborating on a gates of oblivion
inspired music video additionally we're
in the process of creating a custom
dagon axe guitar fit for a four-armed
daedric prince
join us on a journey to create a
one-of-a-kind double neck guitar and see
how you can enter for a chance to win it
so about that music video we'll be
premiering it at the end of the show
today so be sure to stick around but
since we're making you all wait we have
a special treat for everyone right now
have you ever wondered what one of our
bard songs would sound like metallized
we asked matt heaphy the lead singer of
trivium to put a spin on one check out
this incredible piece
[Music]
singing
a time falls short as shadows grow long
mighty spirits with wide eyes read
woofing stay sharp
to save the pack
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
they empty your chest
[Applause]
[Music]
now back to deadlands
how would i describe the deadlines
frightening yet beautiful
as the prince of destruction and
revolution maren's dagon destroys and
reshapes his realm to suit his whims
in the time of eso we visit an expansive
landmass of the deadlands
one dotted with imposing citadels
and hidden settlements
there's plenty of classic dead lands
that oblivion players will recognize
the burn is your traditional volcanic
biome familiar to anyone who's played
tez4
travelers will have to contend with
roving bands of scamps day drops and
dramora
there are also new challenges to face
packs of dream knocking
massive inferniums insect like daedra
that reeve the landscape with their
acidic maws
and finally we'll see a new type of
manticora
birthed by the order of the waking flame
to go along with the burn we have
another biome which we call the sever
this biome is a place of shearing winds
and sharp spires of rock
lightning storms rake across the blasted
surface of this region
the sever is yet another domain that
reflects the abundant natural disasters
that are commonplace in the kingdom of
the prince of destruction
the team here at sauce looked at a lot
of post-apocalyptic imagery to develop
the initial ideas of the separate
[Music]
we wanted to show a land that was
completely inhospitable to life
for the deadlines dlc we knew we'd be
exploring oblivion and that we'd be
seeing daedra in a very different
context from those we've encountered in
tamriel we also wanted to show a side of
oblivion that players had never seen
before a place where daedra could craft
buy and sell equipment and so on
let's turn our attention to the new
mystical city of fargrave
a melting pot of daedra from across the
infinite realms of oblivion
mortals can be found in the city as well
but they are often viewed dismissively
or with suspicion
the city was a great way to think about
life as a daedra
but what do they trade
what is valuable to creatures that don't
need to eat or drink or rest
the art team came up with a really
fascinating mix of vendors and artisans
that we could place in the world
and once we had created this setting
we thought about what it'd be like for
mortals to suddenly show up and suddenly
start shifting things around with their
need for water and food and waste
disposal
that tension was really fun to explore
more abstractly i love how far grave
really typifies the vast lore of the
elder scrolls universe
even the daedra are unsure of the
origins of the city
[Music]
did fargrave and its plane belong to
some now dead daedric prince
was it built by some other race neither
mortal nor daedric
we consider the portions of the
deadlands you'll explore in this dlc to
have two capitals ardent hope a fortress
in the burn and destruction solace a
fortress in the sever
both are seats of power for mayor and
stagon
ardent hope is a hive of activity
we wanted to mirror that with
destruction solace which is more somber
and still
we are all excited about this dlc
we can't wait for you all to jump in and
start exploring daedric culture and the
incredibly unique areas of dagon's
domain
happy adventuring
very cool stuff makes me want to jump
into the content right now which if you
have a pc account you can by hopping
onto our public test server one last
thing before we wrap up we've been
working with the incredible cast over at
critical role meshing the world of
dungeons and dragons with the elder
scrolls online
so far in our year-long partnership
we've released two eso one-shot rpg live
streams focused on the gates of oblivion
adventure and the final one shot is
almost here the staff at grell knox
skull will be back this october keep an
eye on our twitter facebook or instagram
channels for tuning details but in the
meantime check out the first two
installments on twitch.tv critical role
there are loads of activities you can do
in-game today following the stream let's
do a quick recap so we can give you what
we promised earlier more trivium
goodness all right here we go
eso deadlands comes out november 1st on
pc mackinstadia and november 16th on
xbox series xns xbox one playstation 5
and playstation 4.
the prologue for eso deadlands is
available today for all eso players also
live today is the bounties of blackwood
event available for blackwood chapter
owners
we announced spanish translations are
coming to esl in 2022 we'll post more
details about this on our website in the
future
and remember for the bounties of
blackwood event happening now blackwood
chapter owners must work together to
complete enough challenges in order to
unlock eso deadlines for free
you do need to own the blackwood chapter
in order to participate in this event
and reap the rewards last but not least
blackwood is on sale right now you can
grab your copy from our website or your
favorite online retailer
that's a wrap stick around we'll be back
in just a few minutes for a special post
show to unpack more deadlands with some
members of the eso dev team
i think it's time for more trivium check
out the world premiere of trivium's
newest music video the phalanx
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
is
[Music]
[Applause]
up
us
we are the ones who left the
way to hell and misery
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
up
wow
to play
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
[Music]
now i realize there is nothing to say
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
kill me
me
from
[Music]
[Music]
if they should take me
then may they break me kill me
burn me but i'll stay tuned
[Music]
hearts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks everybody
[Applause]
hey rich can you
please not
thanks man
please
here
mighty spirits
to save
[Music]
hey everyone we are back thank you so
much for hanging out for the official
post show after that big reveal that we
had
i i hope you everybody enjoyed the video
i know we definitely did we had a lot of
fun making it
um before we get started with everything
uh we saw some of you asking in chat
about how to get that really cool
nibbanese pony pet through twitch drops
um yeah
yeah it's it's a nice one here you can
even show it off here
so brand new it is brand new first time
you're able to get it um you can still
earn this during the entirety of the
post show
um and once you've watched for enough
time
you just have to claim it through the
twitch ui so head to twitch.tv slash
drops
you have to make sure that you claim it
there but then once you do it'll just be
sitting for you in game you just have to
go to your collections and it'll be
right there for you
so
um
welcome
um welcome everybody yeah today um
during the post show we're going to be
doing a live q a with our creative
director rich lambert
and our lead gameplay designer rob
garrett we're very excited to have them
here
hey
hi guys
it feels like just yesterday we had you
on
it does our most recent guess we just
had to have them back
um
so just a reminder that we are going to
be focusing on the deadlands and update
32.
i said 32 i didn't say 23 this time
congrats you know thank you good job
well done thank you numbers are hard
um so we did pull all of the questions
directly from the official eso forums
and that was across languages too our
territory community managers helped us
pull some questions from non-english
speaking language uh territories as well
yes
so i grabbed a bunch of questions we're
going to answer them today um we're not
announcing anything big today so we just
want to put that out there initially
keep expectations on check
hey before we get started um
i see some people asking in chat
about the shirt that i'm wearing jess is
actually wearing the same one yeah but
i'm a little closer
so jealous
so this shirt actually just went up for
pre-order today
i can just show you a bit of an
announcement huh this is
if you head to the bethesda gear store
you can pre-order this shirt now through
the end of october so it'll only be
available to pre-order this month
but this is like
the ultimate metal t-shirt a nice mashup
of eso and trivium
this is our maroons dagon
like
metal shirt and i love it i think it's
one of my favorite shirts that we've
ever done
it is a really cool design yeah the dogs
like it too hi beethoven
no that's beethoven we have the front
door open and of course
he sees anybody walk by and he starts
barking yeah that's your first mistake
is leaving the door open
come on rookie mistake
all right so should we dive in and get
started with this q a
i think yes yeah
yeah so we had a variety of topics that
were posted on the forums going anywhere
from the new armory um
the armory system or some combat
questions we had some lore questions the
zones so we're going to kind of touch on
a lot of different topics today
but first
i wanted to start with a question about
the armory so if anybody missed it this
is coming new in update 32 coming out
november
and it allows you to essentially save
and swap builds which is pretty awesome
we did have a lot of questions about um
some of the things that is included in
this system so the first question i
wanted to ask it was from uh izangi
asking will the armory system be
available in cyrodiil
rob do you want to tank that one
sure
we have certainly seen a number of
people ask this question uh so for
for
the launch of
the armory system in
update 32
it will not be usable in cereal your the
assistant will not work there
we have
so our reasoning there was we we wanted
pvp and timed activities to be we wanted
to somewhat preserve integrity there the
intent of the system is
make it easy to switch activities and
roles not necessarily optimize your
build moment to moment within an
activity
that being said we are having
discussions about
is there anywhere we can make that work
is there a way we could do that where we
would still be hitting our goals and not
be
again
harming any of the integrity of the
activities so no promises at this time
uh it will not be in cereal for 32 but
never say never
now a follow-up to that that we hear
pretty frequently is um
if we would consider letting players use
the armory assistance during trials and
dungeons
so actually you can use them in dungeons
i think there's been some confusion
around that specifically where we we
don't allow the armory to be used right
now is is timed activities
so
that's
a
timed and leaderboard activities where
you know how quickly you get through the
activity affects your score and
potential rewards so
trials arenas
that type of thing but dungeons you can
absolutely uh pull the assistant out and
your party members can
leverage the assistant as well
awesome cool thank you
then a another question from
izanagi
they wanted to know will dark
convergence
continue to be allowed to pull players
outside of structures with placements on
walls
i mean that's just
yeah that's a bug
okay so no
that's good to know because i have seen
a lot of people asking that as well
yeah yeah the team team's working on
that it's certainly not intended uh also
going back to i realized going back on
the uh the previous question there with
the
uh the armory system
the intent there on not
we know that on pc there's add-ons that
let you do some swapping of stuff when
you're in a trial or whatever but
our concern is
we we try specifically not to be a
pay-to-win type of game and we think
that allowing assistance to be used in a
leaderboard activity kind of
crosses that line for us right where uh
we don't want you to be able to
completely swap everything out so again
that's a good point those decisions are
more it's less about ah we don't want to
give players fun things and all the
convenience it's more of a we want to
make sure we're preserving the integrity
of the game especially when it comes to
competitive play because that's what
leaderboards are right that's a form of
competitive play
rob your cat decided to
i see chat going crazy about the cut to
be agreeable
hi malcolm
are we going to turn this into a pet
stream without a cat i know yeah a pet
post show of course we will yeah of
course
mine followed
doggy dad upstairs
so they'll be up there for a bit
all right let's see um so i think the
next one is yours yeah i can grab the
next one um i did see a couple people
asking again about the pony so if you
did miss the explanation um you just
have to make sure that your eso and
twitch accounts are linked
and then watch um
drops for this started at four o'clock
eastern so about a half an hour ago but
we'll have them on throughout this post
show so as long as you stick around and
hang out with us for a little bit you'll
be able to earn that nibbanese pony pet
this one
and once you do you'll get a pop-up in
twitch chat that says that you've earned
your drop
you just have to go to twitch.tv drops
and then press the claim button i think
you have like 24 hours to claim it and
then it'll just show up in game
like magic
so make sure you stick around and get
that really cool pet and just in case
anybody here is new because we know we
have a lot of new viewers right now i
think we're on twitch front page which
is really awesome um i just wanted to
introduce rich and rob for a second um
rich is our creative director for eso so
he kind of oversees
a lot of the
game design and decisions that go into
the game
that's
that's your super high level of what
rich does but he is a busy guy that
handles a lot of things
and rob as our lead gameplay designer
oversees um all the different gameplay
teams so combat pvp ui systems
what am i missing
is that all of them rob
uh but it's a monetization design yes
yeah
so um we wanted to have rob on here with
rich because we do have a lot of
questions about the armory system coming
up in update 32 along with some
itemization questions combat questions
so rob rob is the guy here
um going back into
uh the questions that we pulled from the
eso forums
we have one from
nick ferzin
doing the best we can here um
he was asking how's cold storage npc
repathing server upgrades all those
things coming along any other
improvements that you're planning
and so for reference about the server
upgrades that nick mentioned and
somebody else actually asked a similar
question
earlier this year when we had our
blackwood chapter announcement i think
in january we talked about um new
servers and kind of what that means um
but since then new server hardware new
server hardware not actually new servers
so um
i think that players are just kind of
looking for an update on how all that is
going
sure so i guess the first one there the
cold storage we're actually turning that
on
very soon in the next week or two we're
doing a first run through on xbox xbox
eo
eu first
and then as we we're gonna do a server
at a time um it's easier on the team
that way it's easier to keep all of the
things kind of contained
uh xbox eu says ayla as he just messaged
thanks
i appreciate that
um so yeah we're going one at a time
we're taking it slow we have to be
really really careful because this is
database work
we don't want to lose anything you know
it's
and so we're taking our time and doing
it right but that's that's being worked
on right now
and then what about um the server
hardware
because i've i've heard some updates
internally but
anything you can share with everybody
else
yeah so that one takes is going to take
a lot longer you know we're in the midst
of a global pandemic
it's really hard to get the hardware um
but we are you know the the process is
get all the hardware
burn it in you know test it install it
you know it takes time to do that it is
in progress we are working on it but
it's going to take some more time or
sure so it's not something that's going
to be completed this year that's what it
sounds like probably not no yes
rich um going back to sorry rob go ahead
i'll see with that performance stuff
also it's the
kind of thing where
a lot of times with these things as a
player you may not even
immediately experience a thing when it
happens right like it's it's uh
it's a
attack from a thousand different angles
on it right and so it's it's
it should be that over time
players would uh be generally getting
better performance but it's not like we
flip some switch and suddenly it's like
everything is perfect now
yeah
yeah yeah um and when we were talking
about cold storage um a few people in
chat are asking what does that mean it's
not like
temperature cold right
right
what that basically means is
we are going to separate the active from
inactive accounts
so that we can make it
so that the the active database is just
full of active accounts it makes the
database smaller it's easier to load
it's easier to parse it's easier to save
and all that other stuff too
if you're in the inactive
the first time you log in it will take
you a minute or two maybe up to three
minutes to fully load that character to
transfer that character from cold
storage to the active database and then
once you go through that the first time
you'll be in the live database and it'll
be back to what you would expect
are we at a point yet where we can talk
about what defines inactive
like how long
no we're still figuring that out but it
will be a significant amount of time
like it won't be 10 days it'll probably
be more on the likelihood of like 180
days kind of thing okay
cool
all right and again that is um a lot of
that work has been kind of going on in
the back end a little bit um we have a
forum thread stickied
um
i forget in which category but um
basically explaining you know this is
why maintenances have been a little bit
longer recently we're doing a lot of
prep work for this and like rich said
the first server that's going to get
this is xbox eu in i think a couple
weeks we have the date in the forum
thread so um once that rolls out we'll
have a better idea of the rest of the
servers and when we plan on doing those
so we'll definitely let everybody know
all right next question is from fizzle
101 another armory question
really looking forward to the armory
function as a console player
if the current technological
challenges can be mitigated
is there a chance of seeing mundus
stones included in the character build
i am also very excited about this
because i also play on console by the
way so um that is my primary platform um
so
yeah we we've seen the questions about
wonderstone for sure
um
it's actually something we talked about
we wanted to make sure that we could get
this
feature ready for update 32
we have been considering
mundustone but it wouldn't have fit to
get it in this update it's certainly
something we're considering going
forward but i can't promise
there's still some
details we have to work out on that and
i can't promise if or when it would
happen but it is absolutely being
discussed
awesome
all right um
few people may have come in after we
talked about this so we did see some
more questions about our t-shirts our
mehron's dagon t-shirts so these are
available now in the bethesda gear store
you can pre-order them um
throughout the month of october no
that's okay we're all still at home it
happens
um
it is on the bethesda gear store you can
pre-order up until the end of october so
um
if you are interested they do look like
this and they are really cool so head on
over to the store you can pre-order
there
next question from redfeather on the
forums if the roaming bosses in the new
dlc are liked might we get other roaming
bosses in the future they're so cool
they are really cool these are something
new that's in the deadlands dlc in that
area
so rich what do you think i really dig
them
uh who knows what the future holds but i
think they're pretty darn cool
um sounded like a heavy hint to me
[Laughter]
all right so switching over to
deadland's content what's
the name here
crow25519 asks what's the story
behind the design of the new house in
fargrave
osa ascentium
it looks beautiful was the housing team
inspired from somewhere i would love to
know
the biggest kind of source of
inspiration was
far grave itself like fargrava is super
unknown
uh even the inhabitants don't really
know where it came from i'm not going to
spoil all the lore in the story because
you can actually dig into it a little
bit in in the dlc
um but really the team was like what
would a house feel like in far grave you
know there's these giant skeletons just
kind of laying around out in the out in
the distance
what would it look like what would it
feel like to have a house there and so
that's that's really where their
inspiration came from is digging into
that and i think they knocked it out of
the park it's an amazing house
awesome can't wait for everybody to be
able to explore it
yeah and um for reference
some of these players are seeing the new
houses and the new content on our test
server so deadlines update 32 is on the
pts if you're interested in checking it
out you can head over there if you're a
pc player
and um
check out a lot of this new content it's
really really cool but it will be
launching in november for all platforms
so the next question from
hillgrim on the forums
the new dlc is going to add dlaa and
dlss support for the rtx 20 and 30
graphics cards it's great the game is
developing in this direction but now
during the global microchip crisis which
as an aside oh my gosh
you should see how hard my husband was
working trying to get one of those cards
he finally got one
uh hilgren said the prices for the cards
are very high and judging from
statistics a small percentage of players
actually have these cards so going to
the question um does the studio have
plans to add fidelity fx super
resolution technology to the game which
is supported by more video cards and
like the lss improved game performance
that was a mouthful but
that was a big question that was a long
question
oh man so i
i don't know if i should actually
say this or not but if you have to ask
you probably shouldn't say it but say it
anyway
uh
yes at some point we will it's cool
technology absolutely
something something forgiveness
permission
it's out there now nobody can hurt me
i'm at home right now so we're good
well to be fair like
who who's gonna who is rich gonna have
to ask forgiveness from
maybe there's only a few people maybe
i just got a message from ayla steve is
driving to your house right now
well then we need to hurry before steve
gets there so we can finish up
you'll hear the dog sparking in about 10
minutes they're safe
all right we've got another armory
question this one is from cilian3117
if costumes can be linked to a build in
the armory system will we be able to
link different mounts to the build too
so
primarily again um
so i mean this is kind of a gray area
question right because primarily the
purpose again of the system is
let you switch activities and rolls
we do have outfits on there as that is
correctly pointed out
that is a little bit more explicitly
even though it is cosmetic people do
tend to tie that more explicitly into
their build so that they look cool when
they're performing these actions
but
currently no we don't have mounts tied
to that
um
and the mount is also a single option
right like that's it's a little
different than configuring a whole set
of gear or something like that right so
it's it's a single single collectible
that you're switching out so
no plans right now and and definitely
with 32 mounts will not be part of the
armory
okay
all right we're going to move into a
couple lore related questions
for deadlines
so the first one is from the saints one
of our german players asking how did you
come up with fargrave i couldn't google
if it's new or existed before so did you
have to bend the lure for like a
peaceful friendly daedra
hmm
oh
yeah i mean it's it's it's definitely
something that we
just made up
um you know the one of the
interesting things about
the elder scrolls lore and kind of this
various different realms of you know of
nirn and oblivion is there's kind of
little bits and
pieces of you know realms that kind of
fit in between and so what we were
looking for when we came up with
fargrave is
um
how do we get kind of like a
a friendly and i'm saying in quotes
friendly because
daedra really aren't super friendly but
you know a friendly city that players
could go to
that made sense like it doesn't make
sense to have a friendly city in the
dead lands right like this is maroon
stagons around
um
spoilers there may be one as you start
to explore a little bit but it's a small
one um it didn't make a lot of sense to
have like a giant
open free city that may ruins daggone
like so we we tried to figure out what
that meant and sorry for my dogs
drinking in the background
slurping away
um so yeah we we needed a space that was
a friendly space that players could go
to and kind of use as their base of
operations and that's what fargrave was
very cool thank you
um we have another one from gaius marius
i bet they're an imperial
what is the difference between an
oblivion gate
and an oblivion portal
as it seems to me they're the same thing
just with the different doors so to
speak and both are used during the same
time period for example oblivion gates
and valenwood during the city of ash
dungeon and in blackwood with the rock
grove trial
i think the best way to think of it is
the portals are kind of like the final
version of his technology
so that's what the gate is right like he
can move his armies freely to
through back and forth kind of thing and
the portals are still kind of that
initial kind of nascent technology so he
hasn't quite figured out all the things
all the kinks yeah so the beta version
it's yeah the beta the alpha whatever
you want to call it it's the
you know pre-800 to a thousand years
version uh and he's refined his
technology after after our time period
very cool
even the daedric princes did prototypes
[Laughter]
all right next question is from our
friend rykoth asking um question about
the armory
he says while swapping between builds is
free does one still have to spend the
coin to respect and make the builds
first to save them or is there a way to
make the build in the armory system
itself
lots of armory questions there are yes
so
yeah so when you set up a build
initially setting up a build
is unchanged from how it is on live
right now
you you pay your respect cost all those
things
the
the key to this system is that once you
have saved the build
then loading that build allows you to
bypass all those costs so yes initially
setting up a bill you might have to pay
depending on your current state and what
you're changing you might have to pay
some respect costs but once you have it
saved and then you load it
it's you it's free at that point
nice
that does make sense
seems like it's a really good value
especially over time
awesome okay so
next one is from tia fry
is it possible that the city of fargrave
being a hub in between realms will
somehow host portals to other planes of
oblivion in eso's future aside from
already existing portals to other parts
of this year-long story
that's a really really really good
question
that i'm totally not going to answer oh
that's a really good question
he got smacked for the last question he
wasn't supposed to answer
i like it i like where your your mind is
at for sure
all right so um
let's see where are we boy i totally
lost my spot here we go okay so uh
moving into
a couple combat questions
rob
um so
tommy the gun is asking if we're going
to see further hybridization changes in
the future what are your plans and
vision for the game in that regard will
spell damage and weapon damage at some
point just become a unified damage stat
wow yeah so
this is a big topic yeah and
hybridization is something that we
talked a lot about in our update 32
combat preview we got into
a lot about that topic in there if
you all haven't seen it yet you can
check it out on the forums it is sticky
at the top of the combat section
just for reference um so rob do you want
to kind of get into
kind of this direction of hybrid and
playing as you want and all of that
i mean anyone who's spent time with the
game knows that um
while when you're leveling up
distributing your points and all in in
gear
especially when you're doing overland
content
you can get away with pretty much
anything but as soon as you get into
more veteran content in pvp
the game very much encourages you
to
push one direction or the other
especially if your dps are healing it's
basically you're all stamina or you're
all magicka
and
that also means that there's a number of
abilities and morphs and those types of
things that
almost become
unusable to you
and so
this is something we've been wrestling
with for a while for sure trying to
figure out how do we open up more
possibilities for builds
so
we've considered a number of approaches
to do this um
at the same time we're also trying to
make sure we don't break anything while
we're doing this right like some some
options we could go pretty heavy-handed
and it could be pretty risky uh eso is a
game that's seven years plus there's a
lot of stuff that's built on top of the
existing system so we've been trying to
figure out
ways that can still be very effective
but also less risky to the overall
system so this this was one of our
bigger ones this this update with the
the weapon and spell damage
being hybridized on the item sets and
such
but ultimately yeah that the goal is
still
it's part of the play the way you want
thing right like we want to make sure
we're maintaining good game health but
we want to try to open up more build
opportunities wouldn't it be cool if you
could actu effectively be taking
stamin more stamina and magicka
abilities on your build um and also
opening up more item set combinations
and those types of things so
something we're still continuing to work
on um
and
super interested to see what players do
with this update i know there was kind
of like a shock at first when players
saw the patch notes or the combat
preview
definitely encourage you to play around
that being said
my understanding is a lot of the
feedback right now is as people are
actually digging in and playing with it
they're the lights are kind of turning
on the gears are turning up oh wait a
minute there's some interesting things i
can do now so
definitely
encourage people to play around with it
on pts or
when the
update launches at the beginning of
november and
yeah let us know what you think and
we'll be continuing to explore
possibilities in this space but i'm not
going to talk about any future changes
at this time
fair thank you
oh um before we move on to the next
question i did want to mention something
i forgot to mention it at the beginning
of the stream but we did have a tweet
about it we have a really cool giveaway
that we're going to be doing a little
bit later
i can show you what it looks like so we
have a signed
assigned cd from trivium
and
maybe
oh the glare is horrible i'm sorry oh
now you're looking at my desktop but
anyway here i'll zoom it out a little
bit so
um this is signed from the band trivium
and you saw the um their newest music
video earlier
did the bard song cover which was
amazing so we will be giving this away a
little bit later during our post shows
so if you want to try and win stick
around we'll do one of those like i
don't know a keyword or something
so you have a chance to win but um
oh it's not look it's not even sealed
because they sign the inside
so oh that's cool i am touching the same
area where matt heaphy
signed
with the pen
and now you know what we have to do gina
we have to get him on a stream sometime
yeah funny you say that
he does
and
i'm not going to say anything else
because we just love teasing things but
that is a great idea rich
oh man
but he is here and he yeah he plays he
plays the game and he played before we
ever started this
collaboration it's really cool he has a
twitch channel too i think he was live
earlier i don't know if he still is but
yeah matt
heaphy not
our matt fire sorry did i make it weird
saying that i was touching me i'm sorry
i'm sorry i just got so excited
um
yeah he was streaming earlier and a lot
of times he'll stream himself like
playing music creating music it's really
really cool so if you're a trivium fan
definitely go check out his channel
but after our post show stick around a
little longer because you want to try
and win that cd
okay just wanted to mention because i
know we put out a tweet you know a
couple hours ago mentioning that
jess do you want to take the next
question
uh we actually have one from the saint
here
i think well
we did we talked about that
it reminds me of um
what was it in uh was it zoolander where
he's like but why male models and it's
like i just explained it
i just went over that
all right i guess we covered that one um
all right so this is from gaius marius
um what's
with the oblivion portals spawning in
the deadlands is it a clown feud with uh
with all the daedra or is it dagon
invading himself
well that sounds
i'm okay nope
to keep his dramora in perfect fighting
condition
it is definitely the latter
it is
it is definitely just keeping his
his uh
followers on their toes he's all about
destruction and battle and all that
other stuff and so he's trying to
make sure
gosh
this is a family-friendly post show okay
goodness gracious we haven't even
uttered a curse word yet
yet give it time yeah yeah we still have
time don't worry
all right a question from
uh
aaron
reg put b 16 underscore eso um how were
how will hirelings work with the armory
system for example if one armory slot
has higher links and the other one
doesn't
do you have to make the higher link slot
active to get the loot
you say that name again gina that's
important
a roon wretch
16 eso
[Laughter]
so uh so hirelings hirelings are based
off of passive skills in your crafting
lines so
and we talked about this in the previous
stream but
the
interface for the armory
it shows you a bunch of things that it
changes but it doesn't show you
everything that it's saving and loading
for example your
um your
quick slots right
but also while your hotbars change out
it's also swapping out all of your skill
points so if it's super important to you
to get those hirelings and have those
those males show up you should make sure
that your skills your skill points for
the hirelings are invested on your
current
setup like your current build that
you're wearing
um but it will save those skill points
so if you swap to a build where you have
the hirelings you will have the higher
links
okay thank you that makes sense thank
you rob
all right next one is from sunny today
since there are so many quality of life
improvements in this update especially
when it comes to rng drop rates does
this also improve antiquity lead drop
chances
that is a good question
um but no it doesn't the curated item
set rng only affects things that are in
the item set collections or your sticker
book
um we may or may not do more in the
future but right now it's just for the
sticker book stuff
there's a lot of item sets to go through
so
yeah that is true
we do have a lot
all right we have one that is is similar
but different from eso nightingale
so following the changes to elemental
succession set
and given the reasons for the change
explained in the logs do you have future
ideas to make the
you agree oh my goodness i can i always
get tongue-tied with this one
yagermore's birthright and why do you
touch that
better via having more powerful and
plentiful supporting skills especially
for egremor's birthright the biggest
underlying problem with the set is the
severe lack of viable damage options to
go with it
that is an incredibly detailed question
we have a lot of those yeah
yeah
i um i mentioned this earlier
i'm not going to be talking about future
combat balance changes that would be
speculating right now a lot of our
changes are based on
both the feedback that we get from
players but also um observing some of
the data right where we're seeing how
things are being used whether they're
effective so
no comment at this time
okay rob pleads the fifth
good question though
it is
you're allowed to do that only once
during this q a
what
[Laughter]
only once huh we um we are kind of
nearing the end of the q a um we are
still going to do the giveaway of the cd
over here i'm keeping it safe so don't
worry
twitch drops are still on if you haven't
gotten your pony pet yet
um you can still earn it for the entire
time we're online so if you need a
little bit more time don't worry we'll
still be live for a little bit
um for the next question from acadian
paladin
any plans to incorporate armory-like
features for companions
i don't need my characters to change
their gear and skills but i sure would
like to be able to easily or quickly
turn miri from a ranged dps to a tank
assuming they have the appropriate gear
and trained up and all of that
i can understand that perspective uh it
it's i can tell you it will not work
that way in 32
um and we don't really have
active plans right now to integrate
companions into armory but
one of my favorite sayings you know in
game dev is never say never
well that's for sure but that is true so
instead of pleading the fifth rob is
going to never say never it's okay
are we dating ourselves by saying we're
giving away a cd like everyone knows
what a cd is right i see some people
like how do you what do you do with
that oh like don't go
really
i mean you can't sign a digital song so
it's going to be the cd
and it's still really cool okay
some of the consoles that you get now
you can't even put the disc in
hey i remember back in my day when we
had cassettes and you that's how you
would record songs is listen on the
radio wait for the song and then press
the button real quick it makes your
videos so good
i i can date myself when i was growing
up we had an eight-track player in my
house
do you remember um laser discs those
were around for a minute we had that as
well yeah those are like
you still have a star wars laser disc
oh wow
i don't have a player for it i just have
the disc
all right we've got two more questions
yes
so the next one is from spartaxoxo
uh they ask what kind of player behavior
led you to add the joining encounter
functionality to old existing dungeons
and are there any other concerns you
wish to address with the activity finder
in the future
will dungeons that have unskippable
dialogue that you need to progress the
quest to now autocomplete that quest
stage when pulled into the encounter
couple questions well so there's a few
things in that question
yeah i think i'll hit the the first one
which is the why joining encounter
sorry let the herd run through uh the
biggest reason that we did that is it
just sucks when you go into a dungeon
and
the group accidentally pulls or
pulls on purpose the boss and you're
locked out of that event you know
um you go into
uh
any number of dungeons and i'm totally
spacing right now but engine guardian
dungeon it's the two i can't remember
what the dungeon is
um you go in there people there's a tiny
little spot where you have to go into or
across the door threshold and you can
aggro the boss and i've been in
many random vets where it's the tank and
me as the healer and everybody else is
stuck outside like that just sucks
so that's why we did it we didn't get
all of them in this past because we
didn't have time to do all of them but
we figured getting some
done was better than getting none done
and we'll continue to kind of work on
those as we go sorry dark shade too
that's what i was looking for man
brain fart big time it happens um in
terms
in terms of you know unskippable
dialogue or extra long theater scenes
things like that you know one of the
the pings i get all the time
you know when i'm running dungeons and
whatnot is when are you gonna fix dragon
star arena so that it doesn't take 45
minutes to speed run through the dungeon
because you have to wait so long for all
the dialogue yeah um
you know that is a harder problem
uh we have learned a lot
since we built that dungeon
um our technology has changed we've
gotten smarter
um
going back we would have to basically go
back and rescript that entire thing to
do it and to get it up to standards i
don't know that's worth the effort like
it works now it's not perfect but
that would probably take a single
designer three months to go back and
research
all of it and test it and get it all
done like it's a huge undertaking to do
that work and
it works i would rather build new things
because players seem to like new things
a lot more than going back and doing
some of the older content that we did um
not to say we won't ever get there but
right now it's just not super high on
the priority list
fair enough
all right last question we're gonna have
a little bit of fun with this one uh
from
ali ivana
what is the name
of mehrunes daegon's axe
is it an artifact he gives out like
molag bal does with his own mace
hmm
good question well so maroons has his
razor
so that is his thing that he gives out
to my knowledge nobody has earned
uh enough favor with him to be entrusted
with his acts so i don't think he's ever
given it out and therefore it probably
doesn't have a name right now
naming contest naming contest yes i dig
like
body mcboat face or slashy mcslash a lot
or something crazy like that that's why
we have final say right
all right so um
we are going to do a little bit of wrap
up but while we do i want to make sure
that we have enough time
for
was that someone's stomach rich are you
hungry
[Laughter]
that was beethoven really building up a
bark to the front door
it's steve at the door i remember
oh yeah
all right so that's right steve is
coming that's good nice gina that was
awesome
oh man some of these messages i'm
getting axey mcax wood there you go
i oh my gosh i don't know how to feel
about that
all right so um in order to try and win
the signed trivium cd
we're making it nice and simple just
type trivium in chat and you'll be
entered into the giveaway to try and win
we're giving away can i enter too
uh you can but if i draw your name i'm
just gonna
redraw well i'm totally answering oh
look moobot even said i've entered so
oh rich so all lowercase nice and easy
type in trivium in chat if you want to
try and win this amazing signed cd
i am really jealous of whoever wins i
almost
when they sent the tracking number i
almost wanted to be like oh it's lost
sorry
oh just gonna have to yeah i'm just
gonna have to you know put this over
here
oh my gosh somebody said they thought i
said mehrunes dagon's abs no axe
yes
do those need a name too people are
thirsty
goodness gracious
all right so um we're going to just do a
brief recap of everything that we
announced during the
event that started at four o'clock about
an hour ago
so just to get started here um the first
really exciting announcement we had is
spanish translations are coming next
year to eso
so we are going to have more information
on this soon stay tuned to the website
we'll definitely put it there as soon as
we have more info
and deadlands which is our next dlc is
launching pc mac
stadia and steam on november 1st
and then for xbox series x and s xbox
one playstation 5 and playstation 4
november 16th
don't forget you can get it for free if
we hit 100
during the bounties of blackwood event
but what is bounties of blackout
what is bounties of blackwood so that's
an event that's happening right now in
game that goes until october 12th
you do need to own the blackwood chapter
to participate you can get a lot of
really cool stuff by participating and
when you
fill the meter all the way to full which
you can do by going into the game and
getting the
blackwood pathfinder achievement which
is really easy you just go around in the
zone and go to different locales and you
unlock it
and that adds to the meter which we have
up on the website on the bounties of
blackwood page
when the meter fills you get different
rewards at certain milestones so
everybody just unlocked the pelosi swamp
jelly pet already
because we do count anybody who got the
blackwood pathfinder achievement before
the event started
as well so the next one is the shadows
of blackwood markings which is unlocked
when the meter hits 66
and then at 100
everybody gets a cascading bounty box
which has a bunch of really cool stuff
in it such as undaunted plunder rare
materials
and a tunable crafting stations and a
unique ogram target dummy that's what
you can see here announced
yep
and we announced today you also get the
blackwood
or some sorry the deadlines dlc
for free when it launches and that's all
blackwood chapter owners
so if you don't currently have blackwood
it is on sale right now so now's a
really good time to pick it up and then
you can take advantage of all of these
rewards
um these rewards are actually going to
be available in the crown store for free
once the event ends
or the meter hits a hundred percent so
keep an eye out on our official
channels for that info what was that
gina i was going to say wouldn't it be
unfortunate if we only got to 99 percent
oh sorry
so close
i think you won't do it i think we can i
have faith yes i have faith everybody
can do it
so we also i'm a troll
i gotta get my fun right
um
so the deadlands prologue quest is also
available to play now you can pick up
that quest starter from the crown store
it is free so everyone can kind of get a
little taste of some deadlines content
and finally remember this amazing
guitar that we showed off it was during
um oh cool
oh gosh i'm blanking
yes thank you so we showed this off
during quakecon you have a chance to win
this it's a real guitar
like we know this is like a digital
render here but you can win an actual
double neck guitar that we are creating
so um be sure and enter we have links on
our website
it's been on social
we actually have a short little video
kind of behind the scenes of this guitar
gosh
of the guitar being created that we
wanted to show you real quick it's
really really cool
in these boxes are are the beginnings of
a guitar project that we're about to
start on
uh the game developer bethesda has uh
has commissioned us to build just an
absolute
monster of a double neck metal guitar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
right now what i can say for sure is
this thing is going to be
awesome
[Music]
i mean
i wasn't kidding that's amazing right
yeah really cool i love that shop i want
that i want that when i grow up so i saw
some people asking um who is creating
that it is calderwood percussion so they
make some custom pieces that are just
out of this world so we're really lucky
to be able to work with them to create
that guitar that you can win all you
have to do is enter into the sweepstakes
yes i can't wait to see that when it's
done and all painted
so we also wanted to remind everyone
that
all of our territory
teams across the globe are going to be
doing post shows of their own as well
from october 2nd to october 5th they
will also have drops
you'll also have a chance to get the
nivenese pony from those streams if you
are watching this vod later
make sure you tune in to those for a
chance as well
um
the full list with times and dates you
can find that on the eso website um but
a few of them are australia the uk
germany france poland italy the
netherlands turkey and the middle east
a lot yes they're going to be very busy
over the next few days so be sure and
check out some of those uh post shows if
you're in those areas and you want to
check out something in your language
all right do you all want to know who
won
these same trivium for me i did turn off
my name gina i didn't turn it off and i
pulled a name it is not slash lurk
oh and it is not the bethesda account
i'm sorry
i'm so sorry the winner of this signed
trivium cd is the gamer seal
so i see you have been trying to win
things in our streams recently i could
see your history thank you for joining
us in our streams just so excited that
you won today congrats
i'm jealous so jealous
i have people from the studio messaging
that was rigged
sorry absolutely
so um
if everyone is really good maybe we have
another one that we'll give away at some
points in the future
and by maybe i mean we do two
so we will we will give another one away
at some point tbd
but you'll have another chance but
congratulations to the gamer seal for
winning the sign cd we'll get in touch
with you very soon
and that just about wraps up our post
show so of course we want to give a huge
thank you to trivium um for
sending us not just the cds but for
being great partners recently
they had that bard song cover which was
amazing we got to debut the brand new
single and their music video earlier so
if you want to watch that again if maybe
you missed it or you just love it that
you just want to keep on watching it i
know i watched it a bunch of times
already
um you can head to their youtube page to
trivium's youtube page and it is already
uploaded there where you can check it
out
they've been so awesome being supportive
on social channels too at twitch and
like just really really awesome yes
thank you thank you all
um and again if you're interested in
this t-shirt that we have on this is
available for pre-order in the bethesda
gear store this really cool marines
dagon eso trivium crossover t-shirt that
i am just loving
it's my new favorite shirt
um and of course rich and rob thank you
for taking the time to joining us again
on our live stream yes thank you
this was fun thank you for having us
any time you want thank you
and of course everybody who kind of made
this event possible like
chess was saying earlier it takes a
small village to put these events
together so we want to thank our events
team our marketing team pr
everybody
sales of course yes and then
community team the dev team like there
was a lot of people that came together
and
created all of this for everybody today
so
yeah including gina and jess thank you
absolutely all of your efforts thank you
these types of events really do take
months to plan so we hope you all
enjoyed it thank you so much to
everybody involved yes and thank you to
everybody who tuned in to watch today we
had a lot of new viewers come in we had
a lot of returning players from our
community so thank you for hanging out
with us today
um and of course the calderwood
percussion who is creating that amazing
double neck guitar that you can try and
win too
oh i feel like we're at like an awards
show just thanking everybody but um
we kind of are it's the year-end wrap-up
right it is yeah but yeah we will have
more streams later in the year we do
have another stream planned in a couple
weeks
yep
yep so this isn't the last one we'll
have some more fun stuff lined up indeed
well thank you again to everybody for
joining we hope you enjoyed yourself
today and we will see you next time
have a great weekend bye
bye everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you